Tim Jim Billy Bug entertainment what's
up how's it
going gavon films what's going on what's
going on what's going
on he are for episode four what's going
on
Emma wolf wolf I see on is that what it
says
on spoil it please
skeletons what's going on everybody
what's up Jack
Adam what episode are we up to four four
four four what's up JM OR7 Julian
William
Leonardo RAF what's going on uh it
shouldn't be out for another uh 30
minutes guys
so what's up Evans Evans
films yes I have seen episode four kid
truth this is the the last one that I
will have seen
though what's going on what's going on
what's going on thanks Evan films
appreciate that love you all
too uh what time in Asia
pH are they going to upload it
o I really don't know man I really don't
know okay what episode is out for now
for the public uh tonight is four Adam
tonight is
four hey Isaiah happy birthday people
definitely care um Jerome thank you for
watching all my vids appreciate that um
Emma if you're nervous for this episode
oo you're in for a good surprise
but you'll probably be more
nervous
after thanks Adam appreciate that uh
yeah um this I think is my favorite
episode it's really hard to say because
I think they've all been
great but this
I I don't want to overhype
it right because I don't want people to
like think it's way up here and if you
think it's here then you think it
actually sucked which can happen hey
Billy buug thanks for that Super Chat uh
it's a big episode yeah it really kind
of makes you it's like a WTF moment in
all honesty like there's a there's
there's a there's a there's a few of um
few
moments um where you're like
wow a few actually yeah
yeah uh Dar Williams I I can't I can't
you guys got to be surprised you gotta
you got got to experience it for
yourself I can't ruin it I can't ruin it
for
everybody Jason what's going on man
welcome back thanks for being here again
uh Betto how long till it comes
out 27
minutes aigu AOA most watch YouTu thank
you so much for that appreciate that
appreciate that appreciate
that uh yes two more episodes is I don't
know if that's Al the cat gen or AI the
cat gen but uh oh dang JM I've had my
wisdom teeth removed before too I
actually had the flu right now kind of
sucks
So Hear Me coughing a lot and sneezing
sorry I'll try to M mute my mic uh the
best I
can so uh Jacob what's going on first of
all but but second of all um so when we
receive the episodes
I I can't recall if they actually give
us the titles for
them
it's kind of interesting that you said
that yeah I
I I don't I don't so I people have asked
this and I can I can say it
um basically because because before
people have asked like well how do you
see all this ahead of time right how
does like Disney you know do you go into
the studio stuff like that like yeah
sometimes that happens um like sometimes
they'll have specific screenings but for
the Disney Plus shows they don't do that
they send out screeners so how it works
is they have a dedicated app and it's
controlled uh by or the access is
controlled by another app so basically
you log on the app and it says log on to
the security app get your access code
and that access code changes every uh
like 60 seconds so uh think of like
Google Authenticator I think is one of
them something like that right so it'll
give you access code and it'll it'll
change every 60 seconds and um you go
back into the Disney app um and then you
enter that code and then it unlocks
access and once you watch it it has your
name in a watermark right across the
screen so that way if you screenshot
something or record or something and you
know put it out there it's got your name
on it they're going to sue you etc etc
also every time you log in to watch
something they make you sign a big giant
contract that says you know you won't
record it you won't Sue Etc so yeah Ray
molte thanks for that super chat um
I I this is my favorite episode um and
so when I got all four episodes I like
watched them all a few times did my
breakdowns like one by one so I haven't
actually seen this episode in a in quite
a bit since I got it maybe a month ago I
I just remember this I just
remember the feeling after this episode
for me was like one I was
shocked uh two I was was confused and
three I was just like this is awesome
like like this is just this this show is
so good like hey Leon what's going on
welcome back welcome back
um what yeah I don't know I think uh hea
and for you know Ray for those who asked
um and again for those joining I'm kind
of sick so apologize I'll try not to
cough and stuff into the microphone um
but
I think it was just the feeling that I
was left with after this episode was so
good it was just like I don't know I
just felt like this I just remember
after watching this show I was or this
episode I was like what this is amazing
like I don't know it's just really cool
and like Victor timely you really get to
see some cool just like
interactions and I I think that I think
this I really think this um
series just pulls you in in such a way
to not only like pulls you in with like
the mystery of like hey what's going on
like I I'm really wondering like what's
going to happen next you know what I
mean like but it also just pulls you in
by making you get so invested in so in
in in these characters like OB right and
Victor timley like after this episode I
think you're really invested in
him and and wondering what his future is
can't give too much
away um but yeah um just the whole
environment of Loki what it is I think
has just done so well from the you know
I've said this a bunch of times like
from the background music to you
know just just the visuals of it to the
dialogue between the dialogue is
something I truly enjoy about this like
the dialogue between Mobius and and Loki
and yeah don't worry shant Taylor we're
not uh we're not going into spoilers
we'll talk about that a little bit
after few people asking if Obi is
evil I can I can make the case that he
is evil and it and it and it makes sense
is the thing so
um that doesn't necessarily make it true
right I can make the case and it can
make
sense because
like there's actually confusing part of
this episode this's a confusing line and
I'll explain
after
um I almost felt like it's a lie like an
intentional lie we'll have to see in
episode five or six but I do think Obi
could definitely be bad and I think if
he's been there and he
helped
um he helped he who remains create it um
you know
I
why wouldn't he be loyal to him right
why wouldn't he be loyal to he who
remains since since he was there in the
beginning I mean OB wrote the TVA guide
book for he who
remains
hello there there we go sorry I don't
know what happened I think my headset
died for a second hey Benjamin thanks so
much for that Super Chat nice to meet
you as well welcome welcome
welcome hi thank
you trying to see if you said anything
else but thank you for that Super Chat
great to meet you as well thanks for
joining us live today thank you
everybody joining us live today um the
duration of this episode h
let me see if I can pull it pull up
mine maybe I could tell you
here it wasn't
short episode
four uh about 48 minutes with the
credits little a little tiny bit over 48
minutes with the credits so
403 minutes
right 4 43 minutes
well yeah yeah Loki season 2 is awesome
Alexis yeah uh Mr JJ do you think L will
start recruiting Multiverse Avengers do
you think Dr Strange will be a big bad
War oh Dr Strange be a big bad uh I Salk
England I was there not too long ago my
last vacation I was in suffk um my
buddy and I he lived in he lives
somewhere in sokk or he lived there and
then we went to Scotland and went back
to his
place um so greetings back uh I don't
think I don't
think uh do strange is gonna be a big
bad no will he cause some stuff to
happen sure but I don't think he's a big
bad theme park shark what's up how's it
going
welcome Tasha K if the Marvel's uh mov
Multiverse story line it should make it
a little at least a little bit
interesting I do think um I think the
Marvel is going to be a lot better than
people are expecting it to be I really
do I really hope so at least um con
donah who Warren is there a post credit
scene in this episode no sorry there's
not I wish there was but the way this
episode's end this episode ends
um yeah I feel like I should be wearing
my Mis minutes hat can it go on top of
the can't go on top I'm afraid I might
be able to
hear
there we go Miss minutes hat
boom boom William Shaw I don't think
you're going to be disappointed does
this not come
out there we go I think it's worth
staying up
for yeah so Jason I thought that as well
um because I saw some people saying like
what if Rogue shows up I was like that
would be crazy and and it would fit with
a Captain Marvel storyline right
so I don't want
to I don't really know much about that
so I don't want to really
jump to the big speculations about
that have I watched kingan Ashura on
Netflix right no I have not I don't is
that a name I don't even know what that
is I I'm
afraid
oh it's a manga series
okay no I have not sorry bud no
that's it's not something I'm familiar
with hey Ethan thanks for that Super
Chat and Ray thank you again for that
super chat I wish I wish I could wish I
could tell you I had buddy
no
um most of what I watch now since I I'm
really busy um for those who don't know
I also run a K-pop
Channel um and I'm I'm involved in the
K-pop music industry so I've been really
busy lately so my TV time is mostly
consisted of rewatching comedies that
I've uh I've already watched because
it's easy to not pay attention to in the
background so right now I'm a big big
Bane
Theory Big Bane Theory okay Ethan which
up upcoming title you most excited
for you know Deadpool
3 because I think that even if you took
away everything that I've heard about it
everything that we've heard about it the
cameos and the Multiverse stuff the
TVA I think if you took away all that we
still have a story about Ryan reynolds's
Deadpool and Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
coming together and I think them two
combined with director sha Levy you
can't miss like it's just I just feel
like it's just going to be a fantastic
movie so Deadpool 3 but and then you add
every else that we've heard on top of
that then it makes me super super
excited
so
yeah hey there you go Jason I would also
uh Jason if you could find their
publicist as well and their manager so
they're they're it's really weird ever
since I like started working with like
Disney Universal like these different
studios I've learned things so an agent
is different than a manager and a
publicist is also different than a
manager and agent as well if you could
find all three I would I would email all
three but best of luck to
you uh thank you Zakaria I think that's
how you say that uh Jose R it's called
My Name Warren and then
XO and then I help run another one
that's not personally
mine yeah for those wondering Warren XO
is one that I'm uh I started on my own
um it was for fun I was just doing
reactions for a long time but now I'm
actually producing content um and then
I've been helping run a different K-pop
Channel that I uh I actually I can't say
what it is because of contracts but i'
I've been helping run a big K-pop
Channel with over a million subscribers
for a for a bit
now so but if you want to support my
personal K-pop Channel that I hope one
day could grow to a million subscribers
it's just Warren wa r r e n x
o what's up Barton bnus how's it going
Alexis do you think that the Marvels is
going to bomb the box office uh yeah
sadly I do um I don't want it to by any
means I I think it's actually going to
be a pretty good film I really do um so
oh there you go thanks Mr Anderson Mr
Anderson put a link in the chat yep
that's
it I don't realize how pink it was it's
pretty
pink
all my
like everything I use in like the uh
um letter the the subtext and the videos
and stuff is all
pink
um oh yeah Luna snow yeah she's
certainly a character that I can't wait
for them to adapt uh in the MCU at some
point in time I really hope they do and
they should because uh k-pop's getting
really big just globally so is Miss
Marvel's ending gonna have Deadpool or
X-Men which one would you like to see
more um I'd like to see Leon I would
like to see an X-Men Cameo um for those
who watch my video today you heard my
reasoning I think I think if you had an
X-Men cameo in the Marvels whether
that's at the end or post credit scene
or something like that I think that
would really make people want to go see
that movie and I think it needs all the
help it can
get um
you know I unfortunately I think the
Marvels can be a really great movie and
even if it people said like oh it's
actually a really great movie I think
there's still a lot of people out there
that won't go watch
it so I think having an X-Men cameo in
it would really benefit it because I
think it would make a lot of people want
to go watch it even if they knew who it
was like let's say it was Professor X
and people like hey Professor X shows up
at Miss Marvel and even if you know like
how I think people are still just
they're going to want to go see that
even if they know what happens right so
yeah oh guys I think my chat's frozen it
is
frozen I don't know what to do here oh
hold on oh it's moving super fast
now oh hold on okay we're back make sure
miss any
supers cool sorry about that I didn't
even realize that at
first
boom
okay hey farad thanks man I appreciate
that um Evan films do I think Iron Man's
gonna return yeah actually there was
some type of a
rumor today I can't remember when it
came out
um that
said he might return before Secret
Wars which could be interesting be
interesting very interesting I'm
thinking
like Deadpool 3 but it's also making me
wonder if there's going to be like
another movie that he could possibly
appear in another Multiverse film maybe
Doctor Strange 3 right I mean who knows
what we're gonna I'm actually really
excited for dror strange 3 who knows
what we're going to see in that
thing who
knows uh Evan film which MJ is my f yeah
Johnny I am sick sorry to everybody has
to listen to my horse voice today and me
sniffle I'm
sorry
um I mean Kristen
duns if you're talking movies like I'm
always gonna I always revert back to the
to Toby Maguire Spider-Man uh you know
uh my favorite movie in Phase 4 I think
is
shangi leg magic I think go to say that
hey Taro how's it
going um Grace I I think it would be
cool if they actually brought back Chris
Evans and Robert Downey Jr if they were
willing to do that
but who
knows who knows who know yeah I I have a
feeling I have a feeling Doctor Strange
3 is gonna be pretty great what's my
favorite face Five
movie I
mean there hasn't I'm trying to think of
all the ones that
have which ones are technically
classified as phase
five because I
want yeah I mean we've only gotten two
so far so it's Guardian so far but I'm
look you know as far as
what it's probably going to be Deadpool
3 I'm assuming it's G to remain it's
going to be Deadpool three you oh my
voice is giv out guys I'm
sorry um I Sean I hope Bri L doesn't
really leave but you know have you guys
seen that clip from
her I can't remember who asked her I
think variety or somebody is like you
know coming back for Captain Marvel 3
and she's like does anybody want me back
does even anybody even want that she's
pretty snippy about it but she's got a
lot of hate for it so I
understand
so
yeah Loki King and morvus are
timekeepers you know if it ended like
that I wouldn't I wouldn't be
surprised yeah I have seen this episode
for for uh those asking and
um I it's my favorite
one oh thank you Hiba my my review of no
way home was the best well that was
uh that was a movie that I was really
really looking forward to and I and you
know if you if you followed me back then
you know I I post
about Spiderman no way home all the time
like almost every day so let me
uh I think I got to pull this up in
Chrome to be able to show part of it
remember I can't show all of it but
let's get this
up make sure we're uh there it is right
there first thing that shows up
Loki wait what did it just say go
back oh I thought it says 600 PM eastern
time I was like that that's not right
Pacific time okay yeah so still only
three episodes up right
now no big deal so we're gonna is this
it yeah there we go
okay so at one point in time we'll just
do I remember now Mr Anderson let's do
do a little stopwatch and then boom
there it is cool okay uh how many total
episodes uh there are six just like the
first
season uh Dale how excited are you to
tell us all about this episode um 10 I
really want to talk
about a few parts I don't I don't want
to say anything but I think there's a
lot to talk about after the episode I
really do and I did an Indian explain
video for this and then tomorrow I'll
have a
video about who I think the real villain
is going to
be
Ray Mullin thanks for another Super Chat
appreciate that do I think Invincible
season 2 will affect the way they do
cryy and Thunderbolts considering he
will be playing multip vers of himself
huh I don't know
um from what I've heard he's going to be
very comic
accurate um and I don't know if
like they're going to bring in like the
void and stuff like that
um I I've
with someone like
centry who's like Superman pretty much
right I mean like I just
wonder with Robert Reynolds
like what the story is GNA actually be
let me change this real quick what what
the story is going to
be are they going to have you know
like is he going to break into the lab
like and is he going to get like a super
soldier serum which makes sense because
of they're tying that to like
Thunderbolt Ross and everything like
that
um like that makes a lot of sense
but I'm I'm just wondering how he ties
into the Thunderbolts
specifically like because they're not
going to be able to take him on right so
I'm just like I hope it's I hope it's a
very long-term
thing
um and yeah I wonder how they are going
to kind of deal with his you know all
the stuff going on in his mind and I
wonder if you know his memory it's going
to be rased from everybody I just wonder
how much they're going to stick to the
comic story or adapt it to the MCU but I
don't think it the Invincible season 2
is going to affect it that
much I don't I don't really think
so yeah yeah Mr Anderson that I mean
that's the whole thing right
so I I don't know how they're going to
tackle
that I almost feel like it's like a a a
like almost Envision like a Galactus
cloud from Fantastic 4
movie right
so
H and like like are they gonna are they
going to go the route you know of him
being erased from people's memories and
stuff like that so yeah Ryan baitman I I
think so as well I think he might be
still working for he who remains I think
he who remains is going to come
back do I think ultron's going to back
Ethan I think some way shape or form I
think he could come back in secret Wars
um I think if we
visited the 838 universe that had the
Ultron Bots we might actually see a good
Ultron I don't
know I don't know I don't know I don't
know
so there's a few ways but yeah I think
it is uh who's my favorite Spider-Man uh
toar tell
me let's see
uh check
this where's the
command
yeah
gotcha all right everything set up on my
end oh hold on something's trying to
open and close everything set up on my
end and is not released yet we have
three minutes three minutes oh wait oh
no dang it I every time I refresh it
shows season one first and you see like
all these episodes pile
up so um few more minutes few more
minutes no I don't think world war Hulk
takes place in the universe I just think
it's going to be way different than the
comics like super different I think it's
going to um
I I think it's going to
be a war of Hulks Red Hulk Hulk She-Hulk
you know what I mean something like
that all right
um if you guys got to use the bathroom
or do something go do it now episode's
about to start and
um I'm I'm so excited to talk about this
episode after
I can't wait to hear all your thoughts
like just come in
so I can't wait two
minutes all right I'm GNA have to pull
up the chat on my phone because that's
how I look up the chat
when uh when I stream because I watch
the
show then I oh here it
is one minute people one minute oh look
a Ryan Reynolds
ad oh yeah Mr Anderson like the comic
book story like we don't even have a
main Illuminati in our universe right
now so there would be be no and there's
no X-Men right there would be no
Professor X Illuminati to want to send
him off Earth to to you know protect
Earth and then you know he's already
been to SAR and he's already been you
know the Gladiator Hulk and everything
like that right um he already has his
son who in the comics you know he he
thinks his son dies in the womb of his
you know wife and you know there's he's
not going to stop on the moon to defeat
blackbolt before he goes back to Earth
you know there's
just you just can't do the actual world
Hulk story you
can't but maybe the century maybe
Century will be sort of a Hulk all right
it's seven is it
out I see episode four heart of the TVA
minutes excuse me but I am ready to
start this here we go we're going to
start in five
four three two one let's
go oh you know what that's coming from
the speakers we can't do that
earphones it's not coming through my
headset though there it is
okay there we
go we're doing the recap right
now until it's [__] this is where we're
at right
now just doing that
recap what's up Malik what's going on
welcome everybody we're
started
we are doing a
recap um I'm actually a little bit
behind this right now two three four
five there we go now we're lined
up oh yeah you find out what the secret
is like immediately so be watching here
we
go the ominous noises everything like
dude it's so they do such a good job of
this
show that is loud bro oh my gosh that's
loud all right here we
are so they're basically starting off
with uh Ren Slayer and Miss minutes at
the end of time
here
oh something you have to see this is
kind of cool as she does it
too I love that his dead body is just
sitting
there check this out this SCS
cool so this is the secret you'll find
out right
away
always yeah for sure Jason aesthetically
this is this Show's crazy good I love
that this scene is taking
place
and TVA awaits our
Command remember he doesn't like
Partnerships uh yes Alexa this is the
last one have not seen five or
six
you know
what is it
time there it
is there it
is that's the secret boom
he said I'm sorry I mean he did what
he's got to do
right yeah you helped
win she commanded Kang's
Army
yep she led the entire Army for
King and now of course the two of them
are saying they don't need
him I love the music for this
man and now Victor timley at the TVA
everybody the TVA oh no that's my chat I
need I need my chat right
there there we
go excuse me
sorry yeah I want to know who fought in
the first multiversal war right I want
to know if there were variants of Iron
Man all these people right I mean who
knows with the time travel all messing
up maybe
the secret words that already happened
is the secret words that's going to
happen because we have you know times
working kind of
funky oh hey I'm live right now I'm
gonna jump out of Discord I'll be
back my buddy jumped in Discord how do I
pull back
up there we
go
can you imagine this guy your whole like
you're at the TVA you time traveled you
walk through a magical door people are
trying to kill
you they're the good guys Mobius unless
they said something good about us then
it's
true
I don't trust
anyone yes we are watching it and Sylvia
is here
now the eff vent CL monster thing
watched
me he does a really good job at
playing this version of Kang Victor
timely hello everyone Kyle Timmy welcome
everybody it is out we're watching it
right
now shadey yes the best word of the
Year
well oh you forgot about
her I forgot I forgot about this
part
yeah right Serena ever wasn't clock
monster
lady so see they are building a new
version of the TVA one where they don't
prune but I think eventually they're
going to
manage what does it say Loom unstable
there pot hot fresh coffee chocolate
soup is that what it
says then you're free to wander around
you got to solve this one problem this
part's really cool with
OB
look at him look how in her
o you wrote the TVA and I love this
scene
your work is based on his work and his
briak is based on your
work I actually think this scene is a
lie because we know that he who remains
created the
TVA not Victor
timley could be another sign that OB
could be a bad
guy right
Jason the way that they geek out about
each other though I love
it
looks great
OB
when someone killed you remains syl's
like what up that was me OB he says you
ruined my
life yeah Obie is a great
character
bigger uh Sean everybody's watching it
at the same time so everyone in here is
watching it on their own screen and
we're all just watching it together
that's the whole
point he says Loki's gonna have to hoof
it
[Laughter]
it's a scale figure it's he's like this
isn't
me this person needs to be super
fast
wait gosh he's it's such a good
character uh
uh Serena I have thoughts on that let's
wait till after this episode though ask
me
again it'll make more sense in the end
of this
episode if anyone
can it's you and me see and this makes
me think that maybe there's some sort of
a plan
to make Victor timley he who remains
like you and me like that's a [__] kind
of almost handshake there why are they
showing us that is OB
bad oh con it gets better I like this
part right here
too let M get some
[Music]
pie gosh people keep on mobious about
that leave the man
alone
everyone keeps attacking Mobius for not
wanting to know his life but I get what
he said he doesn't want to know if he
had like an amazing life because that
life's gone he would just be
sad although I do want him to write a
jet
ski
for
Doc is not having it right
now little bit
huh I didn't know you knew that that's
funny
so first of all Brad dude
you all Brad would have to say is dude
Sylvia read my mind she Enchanted me and
went into my mind and found out
everything I didn't give up
anything great acting from her great
acting from her that little lip quiver
that was
fantastic
I think so too
Teresa
she's she's playing to
[Music]
them
the only question is what will
doc what happens to Doc what will she
do I actually told you Mr Anderson if
you
recall oh definitely
Jason
I definitely think he who remains is
going to show up again I think it could
be a part of his plan I really
do H she ended up in the py
room oh this is good good good scene
here good dialogue
here P
land
so be so
pissed
the silence the tension
oh
four
thank you
shed appreciate
that Victor timely Casey OB it's good
people to put Faith
in
we haven't found out who prun Loki
yet
exactly exactly the branch is still
living are because of the good people at
the
TVA this scene is
fantastic
trying to fix what's broken is hard I
love that
line hope is hard I love that so much
gosh the writing of the
show is
fantastic thanks ail HD I appreciate
that yep
then Loki takes control of the
TVA
M what else can you
do h
that's why Loki is going to take over
the
TVA same Mr
Anderson it's up to oh playing gods
playing
God
we are Gods love it see he's saying
maybe it's U up to us to do better than
he who remains I that's why I think like
Loki is eventually going to take
over be he who
remains gosh this episode's it's such a
good one the
dialogue oh this part too crap I forgot
about this part
guess who it
is this scene right here
and
you miss
minutes I'm working on
myself not because of you're gone not
because you're gone ravona you
stupid is that what what you
want oh that's what Brad
wants that's what Brad
wants
and then miss minutes fires up the
machine look at that evil look in Miss
men's eyes
man good for you ducks good for you
ducks
Bradley she calls him
Bradley he can't even look at
[Music]
her
knowing that all of us here would rather
die than follow you out that
door look how evil Miss minut
looks Miss minut is loving
it your bones being
smushed
she just smushed them
all yeah doc docs turned doc turned at
the end she understood and Brad's a
little
punk little
wimp he's just doing whatever he can to
survive meanwhile the three geniuses Is
Here Yeah Daman she just killed them all
she just done smooshed them you
literally going to hear their bones
cracking
hot the mobus just pick me
up for real
Tasha C
Co you have a machine for that for
Coco
dude really wants
cocoa good old D90 stepping
up and then B15 discovers the smooshed
bodies
oh can you imagine how that would look
like just smushed just like 20 smoed
bodies and she realizes Miss menance is
back the Conqueror what
up meanwhile this dude's obsessed with
hot
cocoa
no I insist have some
cocoa have some
Coco and he likes
it
bye
D90 this
guy this freaking
pansy this
pansy
yep freaking
Brad did you download unauthorized games
again no I'm not GNA make that mistake
twice it's Miss
minutes timely is not there
anymore same yeah Jason So timely's Gone
Mr Min is back and and Doc is
dead and the TVA is still falling
apart need that temporal aura
um Alina there's there's some there's
some parts in here it's not horror but
miss m Miss minutes really does uh
Relish in some people dying and they die
in a a gruesome way that's off screen
but you kind of hear
it oh your girls are mad at you
you're both
okay somebody just pruned Brad
already
it's a very small box I love that
line hey that's a good way to look at it
Tasha
yeah
yes Alena uh yep you spell my name
right uh I don't should yeah I don't
know what you mean about my Discord
server this has nothing to do with
Discord the inedible Hulk yep that's the
problem I hate that
clock uh yeah the loom is collapsing and
it hasn't like exploded yet
but that sounds like a noise you want to
hear from farther away I like that
line
this music is so intense
too yep now we see the past Loki is in
their
present
yeah Tasha that was I mean they he had
Hunter D90 with him so they thought he'd
be safe you know a trained Hunter but
yeah that's past Loki in the present
time in the future for
him everyone's starting to realize what
actually
[Laughter]
happens
and Loki all of a sudden realizes it
too
boom I love this this is so cool to see
it's like past present and future all in
one
time present for our main
Loki watching his past version appear in
its future in his present
time and he realizes what has to be
done so cool the way this is shot the
music
I gotta say everybody who's been pruned
it does not
look like it feels very good at
all well promise I promise you this will
make
sense
then the phone
rings who's on the
phone
it's
Obie oh this is important gota kind of
listen
carefully that per prevent people from
using magic at the
TVA so if they turn it off then Loki and
Sylva can use magic it's
important all
right oh oh miss minutes gets creepy
here again too
mocking isn't necessary because she was
glitching and
stuttering this
part you'll never be him
oo that hits
hard zooming into the statues behind
her oh that hits
hard and now Loki and Sylvie have
magic
what do you say X5 fancy or rematch the
way Loki
speaks and there's silv
just pops his head
in come here for a second come
here
oh got
him time for you to return the
favor and but Brad is still there like
gez at the end of this all Brad is just
freaking still
there uh if they make an Iron Man 4 yes
I'll excited for
it just said
safe I feel like OB says that every time
like theoretically and I haven't tested
it I think that's the first time
r glad you're liking it Serena it's my
favorite one so
far welcome he who remains it
says Brad is a new to of the show
yeah he says wait
it should be
me uh I don't I don't think so KB but
you never
[Music]
know no
time
yeah
Aon time to be brave time to be
brave we're still watching the ending
nobody spoil
it time to be
brave
go get him
Victor
spaghettification
dang he's
gone
he
gone and
then and then it
explodes Mobius is like what do we do
what do we
do
and there you
go crazy
huh
crazy I like I was so just not expecting
that at all when I first watched it I
was like I literally gasped I was like
like oh my
gosh uh Dar because that's that's what
they said happens on the first episode
he when Mobius was going to go out he
said you know you know how like when you
fall into a black hole like your your
body turns into
spaghetti uh they even call it
spaghettification they have a word for
it and uh yeah the the temporal energy
outside was too
much and uh his body couldn't take
it so uh
yeah I know
Lily I wanted to tell
everybody oh right but wasn't that just
freaking awesome though what a great
twist what a great
way like a truly great twist that just
makes you that's what I was talking
about like before I was like man at the
end you just like you're in shock but
it's good and it's
like
yeah but I have theories and my video is
about to come out about the theories I
could actually release that video right
now I can release it right when I get
off the live chat I'm a little sick so I
might cut it a little early
today but I see a few people have just
posted their breakdown so I'm going to
wait a little
bit
I'll wait a little
bit uh I don't think they have any
machine or robots or anything like that
Byron I don't I don't think I don't
think they have anything that could that
could do that
um it's funny the TVA is like has like
high-tech but also like old Tech stuff
you know what I mean like it's kind of
funny
so
want episode five now yeah I know man I
mean but I think does this prove that
that Victor was actually good right so I
think Loki's gonna go back in time I
think Loki and silie with he who remains
his temp pad can go back in
time um and I think that's what's going
to happen I don't think they're going to
like die and he's going to wake up and
like gets like a redo I think they have
to consciously remember that syv temp
pad can go back in time since it is he
he who remains his ttin pad and they
could leave and then try it again I
think
that's
yeah
yeah I mean that's my theory uh I I
think because if you recall in the first
episode when they're going over like
everything and they're like no time
travel isn't possible in the TVA and
Loki's like no I just did it and then he
talks he says well she kicked me through
a door that was opened by he who remains
his tent pad so maybe that's how and I
believe that to be true I think he who
remains his tin pad does work in the TVA
because he who remains created the TVA
so I think his temp pad can actually go
back in time so I think they're going to
use that temp pad and go back in time
and and try to do it differently because
if you remember remember there's a
there's a TV spot that says where Loki
is like goes up to OB and he's like what
could we have done differently and
there's also the TV spot where where
Loki's like okay this is going to be
hard for you to understand hard for me
to explain again and then so that
implies that he's going to go back in
time right so I think that's what
happened I'm really glad everyone is
liking this episode and as so as shocked
as I
was because I this was my favorite
episode and I'm so glad everybody else
is uh oh the chair I'm so glad everybody
else is really loving this as well let's
go ahead rate it everybody rate it put
it in the chat what do you think out of
10 this was my favorite episode and that
ending was just like so
unexpected I just did not expect it at
all
yeah manov is
yeah phenomenal Dara
Carlos I know I need it to be next I
need it to be next next Thursday man uh
20 oh really you got a six in there oh
my gosh they're coming in fast okay I'm
seeing a lot I'm seeing a lot
of a lot of hundreds 10 nine 10 10
million or something like that 10 10 10
20 11 7 a lot of
comments yeah a lot of people died in
this episode Daman yeah lot of Leon nine
nice nice nice grou
66 grou order66 oh that's a
username uh genuinely felt bad for time
SE timely Sean yeah I mean I feel like
he he he's he's good uh Barton I don't
know any more spoilers I've only seen
episode four that's the last one I've
seen so I don't know what happens after
this anything I say is just me
theorizing now I I I don't I don't know
I don't know what happens I think they
go back in time and they keep failing
and failing until eventually they try to
figure something out how to fix it or
maybe they can't I don't I don't know I
don't
know yeah but no timely's dead guys like
he turned into spaghetti so unless they
can figure out how to Des
spaghettify somebody that
dude
dead um did ren Slayer die you know I
don't think so I think she got sent to
the you know the void you know that
place kind of at the end of time as well
where we saw all where we saw Loki go
and everybody else go you know what I
mean so I don't think she's dead I think
she's at that place
so yeah yeah yeah Makin Jane I don't
know if you're replying to somebody but
uh uh I don't know if somebody said that
but yeah uh at one point you know OB
explained hey if we restart the system
we're going to lose the safety
procedures and one of those is the thing
that keeps people from using magic so
that's why Sylvia and Loki were like
shut it off so they could use magic
again so yeah um yeah oh what an episode
though right this is great writing I
just yeah yeah no he he he's he's he's
dead um and I think Obie lied man I
think Obi might be bad because we know
Victor timley didn't create the TVA we
know that we know he who remains created
the TVA
they even showed us that at the
beginning of this episode where Miss
minutes played like the flashback where
Kang's like thanks for helping me do
everything that was he who remains that
wasn't timely right we know that timely
didn't create the TVA in the TVA
handbook we know that Obi it doesn't
make sense for Obie to say oh I learned
everything from this 19th century
scholar we know he who remains was from
the 31st Century he literally says that
at the finale of Loki season 1 so I
think that's a lie man I think I think
OB
could be bad I really do man I think OB
could be working with he who remains try
to get him back
somehow uh I think this is planned
somehow and I think he you know I I
think it could be bad I
just super Steve he could be a version
of Kang here's my only thing with that
my only because I've heard you know like
heavy spoilers and uh Paul and Mt over
there who you know good buddies of mine
you know they said that he could be a
variant and like I I like that idea but
at the same time
um why I I if if if Obi was a king
variant then how come he his temporal
Aura didn't work to unlock the system
right they needed a variant of Kang he
who remains to unlock the system
so that to me tells me that OB is not a
variant of Kang but he probably worked
with he who remained since the very
beginning of the TVA helped him build it
helped him with the tech therefore I
would think you know if you if you spent
eons with somebody and you built
something for
them and you know and it runs everything
why would you betray them right just
because some new people who you don't
really know come along so I feel like he
who remains predicted everything and was
like hey this is going to happen this is
going to happen this is what you need to
do and this is going to like bring me
back blah blah blah blah
blah so I
think I think OB be could really be
working with he remains is trying to
make a
return Tesla Majors is dead that that is
funny Malik the king Tesla Majors I love
that people are calling him that that's
really
funny yeah
so exactly Leon yeah she says you're not
him so so that doesn't make sense to me
OB saying I learned everything from this
guy you know 19th century Victor timely
that
doesn't make
sense
uh Miss minutes would have known but
they they could be they still could be
working this whole or still could be you
know doing the plan that could be part
of the plan right and I don't think Miss
minet I don't think Miss minut cares for
Rana at all I think Miss Min is going to
say whatever she can to get to get he
who remains back I I don't think she she
really wants to run the TV without him
because and even at the end when she
says you're not him right that just goes
to show that she's she loves he who
remains right like she she's in love
with him she wants a body so she can be
with him she wants to bring him back I
don't care what she said about being
done with him she could be done with
Victor timley but not done with he who
remains she wants to bring him
back she wants this she wants to bring
him back and I think she probably if
Obie is bad she probably does know
that
yeah
so I mean that's a good point too Miss
Anderson yeah no official SBX yeah she
doesn't care about raana at all why
would she care about raana when she
loves he who remains and he who remains
clearly had something with raana you
know Miss Menace wants raana out of the
way so I think that was part of the plan
um and OB could very well know you know
everything about Miss Min and and
everything about he who remains and Miss
Menace could know about OB right but
you know it's always possible to delete
memories clearly and if you're an AI you
can delete you can delete memories of an
AI clearly right
so
yeah oh we what Riley FG 100% could see
a different variant 100% yeah I and I'm
really hoping we do see more variants I
do think he who remains is going to
return somehow I think that's I think
that's what this is about I think at the
end of Loki season 1 when he said see
you soon I think that might have been
literal maybe he wasn't just saying hey
my variance will see you soon maybe
he maybe he's going to see him soon if
you want to uh like hear my full theory
about this I did a
video couple weeks ago I I did I did
multiple videos about how I think he
remains is going to return how I think
OB is bad how I think this is part of a
plan and yeah I I really do like as sad
as it is I really do think OB might be
bad but I do think Loki and them are
going to go back in time using um he who
remains his temptin Pad
I do I'm about to put that video out
right now I've already recorded the
video
um yeah so I'm about to I'm about to put
it out about to put it out right now let
me this this
so uh yeah I appreciate everybody
joining appreciate everybody
joining uh do you agree is this true due
to Marvel entirely do you think that
spider verse I don't kind of
stopped oh Elena you I forgot you
weren't even watching it oh well yeah
now you know now you're
prepared Ethan buffkin wasn't that crazy
Miss minut looked hella freaking scary
there right she loved to see all those
people die that shows you how evil she
is that shows you how evil Miss Min is
she was like loving it too it wasn't
even just like a little she was like
loving those people got smushed to death
like with each other too not even like
the Box just smooshed one person you had
to deal with literally everybody else
being smooshed into you
like yeah so somehow I believe Loki is
gonna go back in time I think I think
him and Sylvia are going to use the temp
pad I think maybe all of them go through
a door you know and they just get out of
there and they're just like see you see
see you you know
um that's what I think I'm I'm about to
release my whole theory about that video
right now I'm going to end this stream
because I'm sick so sorry to end up
pretty early I know we got a lot
sorry I know we got a lot of people in
here right now but I I really am sick so
going to cut it early but check out my
video I'll release it pretty much right
when I get off here in a few minutes and
um let me know what you think on that
video comment on it give me your
theories but yeah I love I love this
show so far and this by far to me was my
favorite episode so uh no I've not
played Spider-Man 2 yet for those asking
so thanks Leon appreciate that thanks Mr
Anderson thanks everybody thanks for
everybody being here
um awesome glad everybody love glad
everyone's loving it so thank you
everybody thanks for stopping by thanks
for the super chats the regular chats or
if you're just watching appreciate that
as well of course just for being here
and hanging out um next week it's going
to be a ride so uh we'll start at the
same time next week so it's uh about
5:30 Pacific time is when we start about
30 minutes before each episode drops is
when we normally stop so uh we'll we'll
be back a week from now um yeah so be
sure to come back next week it's going
to be crazy uh can't wait to see what
happens the next two episodes and uh
I'll go release my my breakdown of the
ending right now and what I think is
going to happen so thanks everybody
thanks everybody for stopping by we'll
catch you next